nothing complicated i clip in and now
i'm good to go and again the cool thing
about a strap is i can stand if i want
to i don't have to worry about holding
on to the guitar there's no extra device
i have to carry around with me it's just
always on the
instrument today's video is brought to
you by classical guitar pro that's my
brand new online classical guitar course
which is six hours 53 videos it's a
whole curriculum designed to teach you
what you would normally learn in the
first six months to a year of classical
guitar lessons so if you want to learn
classical guitar but are stuck
struggling reading music or struggling
to learn the techniques check out
classicalguitar.pro.com to learn more
hey everyone and welcome back to my
channel i'm joined again by expert
luthier marshall bernay hey marshall hey
brandon it's good to see you again good
to see you again we definitely didn't
film two videos in one day no not at all
never we always wear the same clothes
i'm here today at marshall's shop uh
because i am ready to put a strap onto
another one of my classical guitars and
to do that you have to put a strap
button on the bottom that requires a
little bit of drilling and while i was
contemplating drilling into my guitar i
thought
better take it to an expert he'll tell
us how to do it the right way now a
strap on a classical guitar is a
basically a thing that today i think a
lot of guitarists are afraid of they
think they're not supposed to do that in
a classical guitar they think it's not
uh traditional well let me tell you a
strap is a valid and historical way of
playing the guitar
and there's no reason why you shouldn't
do it today we're going to learn how to
put a strap button on and then perhaps a
lot of you can give this
a go so marshall i have some questions
for you right off the bat all right i've
got answers let's see if we match here
we go
the first thing that happens when i
bring up a strap to classical guitarist
is they say hey i have a 5 000 guitar
i'm not drilling into that guitar
they're worried about i think the the
strap button diminishing the value of
the instrument should guitarist be
worried about that no not at all i mean
if you're drilling into something that's
say
not a historical guitar meaning
let's call 35 000 so probably not that
hauser we played in the last video no it
doesn't yeah uh that is kind of where i
draw the line okay uh
that said you know there i have ways of
filling it and making it look like you
never had a strap button in there but i
have drilled into you know up to 25 000
guitars at the express understanding and
request of the customer i don't just do
it to idly well away a saturday right
okay but so they shouldn't be afraid of
adding a strategy absolutely not
i've got a beautiful uh 67 marmol de la
chico that i installed a strap on there
and that's easily a 9 000 guitar wow and
so
you know if it increases your
functionality and usability and
playability
it should be done okay by a qualified
person so that was my next question is
should they do it themselves
you only get one chance how lucky do you
feel and i believe i said that to you
when we talked about this i was like
drill in hand ready to drill in my
guitar and i was like i probably should
call marshall and he goes yeah don't do
that
yeah i mean there's
i expect it to be fairly straightforward
and generally it's a pretty easy thing
to do the parts are not expensive it's
not difficult but there are things that
can go wrong and
you don't want
to do that because then it gets
expensive
you know un
messing up something
is a lot more difficult than messing it
up
well said thank you so in this first
part of the video here we're going to go
into marshall's shop and he's going to
teach us how to properly install a strap
button into a guitar but as he
recommends probably take it to an expert
and then once we have the strap button
on we're going to talk about choosing a
strap and also how to get the strap to
attach to the headstock and kind of
getting set up in my preferred way of
holding a classical guitar but let's
start by heading over to the shop all
right let's go let's do it
all right so we're going to install the
end pin we're going to need a few tools
we need a ruler preferably in metric
just because it's easier to subdivide
we're going to need a hammer because we
need a hammer we need an awl or
something sharp to get it started with
we're going to need a drill bit that
fits
perfectly so this is a 7 64 drill bit
don't take my word for it measure your
own so you don't mess it up now we're
going to need a screwdriver and
a drill i've got a little notch in my
bench
which i like to use with padding on both
sides
i'm going to measure from along the
center line of this guitar so i'm going
to measure very carefully
93 millimeters that means that i am
going to have to make a
mark at 46 and a half millimeters reach
for your ill-placed tool because it's
never exactly where you want it to be we
say 46 and a half and before you lock it
in make sure it's visually about where
you want it to be okay and then we're
gonna just take our hammer and very
carefully give it a little
[Music]
tap
don't go too hard and make sure that is
exactly where you want it to be because
we have now crossed the point of no
return now uh
some places will say to put a piece of
tape over this that really depends on
the finish of your guitar uh this is a
finish where i don't anticipate any
chipping so i'm not going to put any
tape over it so
uh now i'm going to again visually
center it
this way
and this way to make sure that i'm
running perfectly square
and just very slowly
[Music]
go in like that we can take our end pin
i like to start it by hand just to make
sure it's not going to be too tight and
bind i like a uh what's called a
precision screwdriver
where it's got a
movable handle on the top
where i can push down
with my palm and install
the end strap
right into the guitar
uh making sure that you have the grommet
on here because uh these do rattle from
time to time so i'm not a big fan of
that
so use the grommet it will make your
life a lot easier snug it down like that
now it's installed
thank you marshall you're welcome
okay so i'm now back at marshall's shop
some weeks later i have chosen a strap
and fitted it to my guitar and i wanted
to tell you a bit more about
how i did this since we already had our
strap button installed safely by an
expert
and then the next step was to pick out a
strap
i just ordered a strap online i found
one that i thought was quite beautiful
it kind of matched the flame maple kind
of a yellowish gold
color a bit of a kind of baroque
pattern nice little fabric this is just
a standard guitar strap there's nothing
special about it i like the standard
straps because they're adjustable
and they they're really easy the end is
has leather and they really fit well on
the end pin and they're not gonna come
off so you choose the strap that you
think best represents your personality
um but i thought this went well with my
guitar and looks quite beautiful and a
bit broke putting the strap around the
end button is self-explanatory this is
just you know put the end pin around the
or the button around the leather strap
the leather strap can be a bit rigid
when you first get it so you have to
kind of force it on but it'll get there
and once you get there it's really not
going to go
anywhere then on this side this is the
part for classical guitars or acoustic
guitars that takes
some creativity
normally this side would also attach to
a button installed on an electric guitar
usually
here strap it go from this side to here
but on classical guitars i don't want to
put a button here
so what i do is i just attach it to the
headstock which works really well and
there are a number of ways you can do
that the cheapest and easiest way has to
be the shoestring method so you can just
take any shoestring you lace it through
the end of the strap and then you just
simply tie it around the the headstock
you could put it under the strings right
here at the headstock just above the nut
you could also tie it just around the
whole you know side of the headstock so
it doesn't block any tuners or you can
do what i did here and kind of tie it
around the middle portion
of
the headstock now in the past i've just
done the shoestring method but i found
this nice little clip by d'addario so
it's an easy release clip i can just
clip this on and off whenever i want and
that's an easy way to take the strap off
i just leave mine on
so this little end attaches to the
headstock again i just tied it around
nothing
nothing complicated i clip in and now
i'm good to go
and again the cool thing about a strap
is i can stand if i want to
i don't have to worry about holding onto
the guitar there's no extra device i
have to carry around with me it's just
always on the instrument and personally
i find the strap very comfortable
you have to make sure you adjust it
correctly obviously if it's too loose
that's no good i'm actually wearing mine
quite high
so the guitar is on the right thigh
here and then i kind of have the
instrument at a 45 degree angle the tip
of the headstock is around my eye
level here
and then the guitar itself is high
enough so that the sound hole is kind of
where it right at my sternum so i think
this is a great solution there's one
downfall with the strap
which is when you let go this can happen
right so if the instrument's not very
tight it kind of falls and i have to use
my arm weight to hold the instrument up
or use some muscles in my back to hold
it still this isn't good for classical
guitar tension is the enemy we want to
be as loose as possible so we can
concentrate our
motions our movements
on what actually needs to be done
economy of motion is a good phrase right
we want to be moving as little as
possible so i'm going to show you a
trick which is going to really make the
strap work even better and i learned
this from playing the loot actually so
all you do is you take some type of
string ribbon
fabric i have here just some fabric i
got at the fabric store kind of a
baroque pattern that i was using on my
loot actually i just kind of tied this
around my loot but any type of fabric or
kind of thick string
will work basically we're going to do
this is too long but you know it'll work
all i'm going to do is i'm going to put
this around
the
strap here so i just looped it once
around the bottom of my strap and i'm
gonna take this long end now and all i'm
gonna do is sit on it
and when i sit on it what happens is the
instrument gets perfectly
balanced so it's a butt strap really
so the strap you can make it really
short i would keep it maybe something
like this long you just tie it around
the strap once or loop it around and
then yeah all you do is you just you
grab the end and you you sit on it and
that kind of pinches the guitar so that
when you let go look it doesn't move at
all i can even rotate my body and the
guitar is exactly where i want it to be
which means again now that it's right
precisely where i want it i can focus my
energy on just playing as smoothly and
elegantly
as possible
[Music]
you